hello and welcome to playstation grenade
is it just me or has fortnite chapter 2
been quite difficult to follow
the narrative jumps around and nothing
really gives us the answers we need
well what if i told you everything is
being laid out right in front of us
hidden in plain sight let me break it
down for you
and if this is helpful please throw a
like my way and think about using code
adamaru in the store to keep these
shenanigans going
here's the thing though to start
understanding chapter 2 we need to
revisit the og
island and chapter 1.
when season 4 of chapter 1 arrived we
had our first experience with the power
that would become
the nexus a zero point of unimaginable
energy which was buried within the
island
all we knew back then was that time
travel was possible
we saw a rocket losing control and
warping around the map
before breaking the dome which held us
the visitor was trying to achieve
something but alas
we had no idea what was going on we
needed to go deeper into this rabbit
hole
season five of chapter one once again
blew our minds with the creation of
kevin the cube
a mysterious object produced from
nothing
almost like an external force was adding
things to the island
back then we suggested we were being
watched and manipulated
little did we know we were right but
we'll get to that soon enough
the thing we must note from kevin's
journey in game is from his death
the butterfly event the butterfly showed
us that the multiverse
is real multiple dimensions all
operating at the same time
bridged together somehow something else
we noticed back then was that this scene
in fortnite was very similar to that of
doctor strange
could fortnite and the world of marvel
movies be related somehow
right now in chapter 2 we know a little
more about that secret organization
watching the island
agent jonesy and his governmental men in
black
but even as early as season four we had
seen them in game
searching for something and in season
eight it finally happened
the vault was revealed under loot lake
the heart of the island opened up
and we visited the nexus of control
in here we saw the orb which would
become pivotal to this story
but also a sign of the second visitor
one designed to change our future
and give us control some sort of
paradigm shift was coming
our intrusion in the vault was not taken
well by the island
who wiped out entire locations to
protect itself
but it was too late we knew about the
source of power
and so did that secret government group
the nexus point was real
but then we were trapped stuck in a
bunker until a new world evolved
season nine saw the uprising of the
paradigm her statue stood proud
she had been busy preparing the island
for something
and utilizing the vault's power to
energize the island but also build a
defense for it
in the shape of a sentinel mech we
didn't need to wait long to find out why
the bot was here
the event in that season saw a battle
bigger than anything we'd seen before
a grotesque monster with one mission to
open the vaults
and feed on the energy within but
paradigm had seen this danger
and piloted the mech to defeat the
monster but things didn't go completely
to plan
in a last-ditch attempt to save the
island she broke open the vault
and instead of protecting the nexus she
used it
granting her unbelievable power to
vanquish the demon
we were saved but before any questions
could be answered paradigm's mech
left the island never to be seen again
seemingly
and then season x arrived and the world
is destabilizing first
season x is here and the world is
destabilizing
fast the zero point was now unable to
control itself
or contain the energy it holds leading
to rifts in space and time opening
everywhere
this was the season which many questions
were answered
but even more appeared different
dimensions continued to appear
events from over a year ago were
reconstructed including the meteor this
story began with
preserved in time and held in place upon
the rock we once again saw the visitors
capsule
but this visitor was not the same yet
another reality
had invaded our home the scientists came
to complete the plans of the original
visitor
and continued the work of paradigm and
that's when we were hit with an info
dump
like no other for seven an
extraterrestrial organization
attempting to stop the loop we found
ourselves stuck in we discovered
primitive recordings of the seven
who told us this when i hear this again
will it help me remember or once looped
will i
be just as muted as the others from this
we knew the island is attempting to keep
a secret
and muting inhabitants removing their
memories in the process
we became puppets reliving the same 20
minutes over and over again
loop after loop unable to speak the
seven
told us of a bridge a connection between
fortnite
and every other world and realm in
existence kind of like the one
seen in thor a by frost to move between
worlds
instantly in fortnite this is a floating
tunnel of cloud
we've seen johnsy float through this in
season x this is arguably the most
important thing in fortnite
it's how all the crossovers are possible
the bridge
pulls in other dimensions it's unclear
if the seven wanted to control the
bridge
or simply harness it for their plans but
now the scientist was all alone
and the only one who could complete that
plan to destroy
the zero point the very thing we've been
fighting to save for years
the scientists prepared in the same way
the original visitor did by designing
and building a rocket
he created rifts in time to procure the
items he needed
and then on that faithful day in 2019
conditions were ready
the scientist timed his plan to
perfection and the other members of the
seven
simultaneously used the bridge and
completed their plan
two years in the making destroying zero
point
forever um but we ended up in a black
hole instead
was this really the end and this is
where new information has come in to
help us build the story of fortnite
the man in charge of narrative the
mustard we called donald
has told us this was the exact moment
galactus felt the island breaking up
and reconnecting rebuilding itself the
immense power was so undeniable to him
the eater of worlds spent the next 12
months flying to consume this island
and we had no idea
and now we've made it to chapter two a
new world to discover
the island felt familiar and
simultaneously brand new
and now we know the nexus simply remade
itself
like a reset button the first season we
were here was all about duality
two factions are a running theme in all
seasons this chapter
starting with ego and alter the ego
squad was the first to arrive here and
quickly found their doppelgangers
and the war broke out this was also at a
time when secret agents were seen
watching from the background
but that doesn't become apparent until
season two the season
we found midas midas is completely
different from other fortnite characters
he could turn things into gold by simply
touching them like the legendary story
you heard at school
but somehow he remembered more than the
loop he was stuck in
we think this is due to his golden
ability each mask
representing another loop and although
he is unable to speak
he had a plan to break this cycle the
altar and ego factions were replaced
with ghosts and shadow this season
midas set the two sides to fight each
other all the while
watching through his agents this was a
diversion because midas was able to
remember the loops he was part of
and that all his actions were futile
except they weren't
the island remembered core changes like
map updates after each loop
so midas hid away an update in secret
underneath the agency
midas was building a reactor but why
might as quickly figured out the island
was not the reality he accepted
and discovered this was a hub world
which others passed through
i suppose seeing a man advertise his new
star wars movie
was the moment of that realization midas
took it upon himself to break the loop
and over the next weeks and months
created a device like no other
one which could harness the storm his
plan was to activate this
at the exact point the loop reset i.e
when the storm circle
began to close then all hell broke loose
if you were there that day you saw with
your own eyes he was successful
well kinda the storm was forced back but
instead of the loop resetting
we were transported to another location
an office
a mysterious place which proves that we
were right
all those years ago this is a simulation
and we are being watched
and the culprit none other than johnsy
the og character we've seen on this
journey for years
in this world johnsy is known by agent
jon jones
and we hear him talking about watching
the island and manipulating the events
suddenly the creation of kevin the cube
and the finding of the vault
and those random characters dropping
into our game all these anomalies
had answers now jon jones is running
tests
on the fortnite island midas had broken
the loop for long enough to hear someone
speak for the first time
but as soon as it happened it was all
gone the words became gibberish again
midas had failed
[Music]
midas was seemingly punished for his
actions and was taken out
at the start of season three by a shark
no less
season three was a return to normality a
flood quickly washed away midas
actions and introduced another dimension
that of aquaman i invited aquaman he
said
it was like we were being forced to
forget what happened in season two and
continue to loop
but we've seen too much by now and as
you know galactus was already on the way
before season four began we saw the
arrival of thor's hammer to the island
four in this version of the multiverse
is the herald of galactus
thor acted like a chaperone to galactus
as they are on the same mission
an entity has arrived in their world
which will devour their reality
completely
and the only way to stop that is to
allow galactus to consume enough energy
from around the universe
to have a chance at saving that version
of time
thor's role is to tell galactus what he
can consume
usually this means thor jumping down to
the chosen world using the bifrost to
save them
before galactus chows down and that's
what thor intended to do this time
he arrives to warn the inhabitants but
the power of this island is too vast
even for a god thor begins to lose his
memory
and his ability to speak he joins the
loop as a player
thor quickly calls for help as this
island is like no other world
heroes arrive but once again the power
of the island
is too strong wolverine becomes an
enraged wanderer in the woods
doom goes back to his natural desire to
rule but others are able to control
themselves in a similar way to midas
tony stark begins to build a way to
fight off galactus
but even he is forced to take part in
the looping events of battle royal
island
however iron man keeps on working using
rifts to bring his home in new
york to the island frantically upgrading
the battle bus
to go up against galactus time continues
to tick
and galactus one year travel to the
island is almost over
just as our heroes are forgetting
themselves and losing their own voices
forever make no mistake galactus is here
to destroy the island
and we must save our beloved home as we
approach the final event it's uncertain
what will happen next
some people have suggested a return to
the original island some people believe
the bunker will finally
open and some say the seven will return
to protect us now's the time to pass
this over to you what do you think will
happen next
i'd like to make next week's video about
your theories on how the story is
evolving
please write a comment below and upvote
your favorites and let's see where you
guys would take the story forward
thanks for your time on screen now are
the people from my discord who kindly
use code adamara in the store thank you
very much for supporting me
next video i'll be thanking everyone who
sent me a code adamaru twitter dm
thank you very much for supporting me i
appreciate it i hope this video was
useful
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure i'll see you next time
[Music]
you